bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du journal voilà ce que l'on
peut retenir en ce vendredi et 27 mars
c'est la bibliothèque universitaire fête
ses 10 ans élèves et professeur
rassemblés à l'occasion de cet
anniversaire en ce moment c'est le
Sidaction des opérations ont lieu
partout en France également à 50 ans en
Yvelines avec l'association un chef
prévention dimanche il vous faudra
avancer vos montres d'une heure avec le
passage à l'heure d'été certaines
associations sont contre nous ferons le
point avec LNR gabarin la présidente de
la sed mais tout d'abord donc la
bibliothèque universitaire fête ses 10
ans retour sur l'histoire de la
structure qui ne manque pas de projet
Mathilde Capvern et Patrick Jacques
odixmude
dans les années 90 c'était un projet
audacieux la Bibliothèque Universitaire
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines naît d'une
coopération entre la Région
Île-de-France la communauté
d'agglomération et la ville de
Guyancourt après 6 ans et un peu plus de
17 millions d'euros d'investissement le
bâtiment est un véritable carrefour
culturel en 2005 la bibliothèque est
déjà en avant sur son temps déjà au
niveau de la construction elle prenait
en compte les nouveaux usages des
bibliothèques et notamment la nouvelle
donne entre le papier et la
dématérialisation ça c'était vraiment un
fondamental et elle marquait déjà une
sorte de modernité dans les
bibliothèques universitaires qui étaient
plus que des lieux de savoir un peu
écartés de la ville mais vraiment aussi
des lieux d'accueil un peu
pluridisciplinaires avec une ouverture
et ça se voit dans l'architecture pour
être un lieu de vie en fait et pas
seulement un lieu de travail même si
c'est avant tout un lieu de travail lieu
dynamique en 2013 elle réaménage ses
espaces de travail en groupe ou en solo
et propose des conférences dans son
auditorium ainsi que des expositions la
bibliothèque s'adapte au fur et à mesure
des usages évolution du parc
informatique avec 70 ordinateurs à la
disposition des étudiants mais pas
seulement on a eu aussi toutes des
choses qui se voient pas mais un accès à
distance de toutes les collections base
de données électroniques
périodique électronique qui avant était
consultable en ligne mais que sur les
postes dans l'université et depuis
quelques années on s'est mis en place
cet accès à distance ou les étudiants et
les enseignants et les chercheurs enfin
tout le personnel toute la communauté
universitaire de l'USQ peut se connecter
à distance sur toutes ces bases de
données la structure ne compte pas en
rester là elle a pour projet de
développer un Learning Center lieu de
travail de culture et de services avec
des ateliers d'apprentissage mais aussi
de détente grâce à l'ouverture d'une
cafétéria
et puis rappelez-vous une collecte de
dons avait été lancée par la fondation
de l'UVSQ pour financer des ouvrages de
cette bibliothèque universitaire à ce
jour 170 580 euros précisément ont été
collectés les premiers livres sont
arrivés et mis à la disposition des
étudiants la campagne de collecte se
poursuit jusqu'au 30 juin afin d'acheter
7500 nouveaux ouvrages dimanche 29 mars
à partir de 18h radio sensation
s'associe aussi d'action et vous
proposera un hebdo-politique consacré
donc à la lutte contre le sida Nicolas
kyrilovic recevra notamment Jean-Luc
Romero le président de l'association élu
locaux contre le sida et du Centre
régional d'information et de prévention
du sida en Île-de-France il est
également conseillé régional
d'Île-de-France et il recevra également
Eddy hate vice-président de
l'association et l'uloco contre le sida
est conseillé également régional PRJ
d'Île-de-France je vous propose un
extrait de l'émission
Jean-Luc Romero quand 27% des Français
déclarent que l'on peut guérir du sida
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire comment comment ça se fait qu'il
y a trois Français sur 10 en 2015 qui
pensent ça c'est oui je disais tout à
l'heure il y a un retour en arrière des
des connaissances et qui est assez
inquiétant notamment dans notre région
parce que si je me permets si vous me
permettez de rebondir sur ce que disait
et dit il faut quand même quand on parle
de la responsabilité des élus notamment
ici en Île-de-France et à Paris elle est
quand même très particulière on a en
Île-de-France la moitié des 4 VIH de
tout le pays on a à Paris un quart des
cas de VIH c'est-à-dire qu'en gros sur
Paris c'est certainement 40000 personnes
plus que les deux premiers
arrondissements qui vivent avec ce virus
donc comment peut-on être totalement
indifférent et dire que c'est pas une
question de santé publique essentielle
dans la région quand on est élu
d'Île-de-France contre le sida
n'intéresse plus personne il faut être
honnête il faut dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont mais qu'il faut plus que
jamais continuer parce que
paradoxalement il y a jamais autant de
gens qui ont vécu avec le sida dans le
monde 34 millions et puis en France 150
000 personnes et sur le terrain les
associations continuent de mener des
opérations de sensibilisation c'est le
cas de l'association HF prévention cette
semaine Jérôme André et ses équipes
étaient à l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin pour proposer des
dépistages aux étudiants des tests
minutes de rentrer
Raphaël est étudiant à l'université il
profite d'une courte pause pour venir se
faire dépister auprès des bénévoles de
l'association Evinoise HF prévention un
test d'une minute précédé d'un entretien
pour savoir si les séropositifs ou non
combien de points un seul donc votre
reste votre test est négatif ok
maintenant je vais quand même vous
demander ce qui est important pour nous
de savoir quel est le dernier rapport
sexuel non protégé que vous avez eu
comme lui 200 à 400 étudiants sont venus
faire le test dans la journée la plupart
du temps par prévention j'ai changé de
partenaire et même si j'ai jamais fait
ça on n'est jamais trop à l'abri donc
c'est toujours mieux de d'assurer le
coup plutôt que se retrouver au final
avec le sida sans savoir là par hasard
aujourd'hui je suis passé devant donc
avec mes amis on s'est dit bah pourquoi
pas faire un test voilà les 27 28 et 29
mars prochain trois jours pour favoriser
la recherche contre le sida le Sidaction
2015 va tenter de collecter un maximum
de fonds à travers différentes actions
dans la France l'infection ne doit pas
être banalisée elle touche encore 6 à
7000 nouvelles personnes chaque année en
France un fléau contre lequel se bat à
chef prévention dans les Yvelines depuis
de nombreuses années à travers ses
actions l'idée c'est de réduire les
risques que les gens comprennent où
est-ce qu'ils prennent donc des risques
sexuels et puis qui puissent aussi avoir
une réponse quand à leur statut
sérologique sur le sida alors les
étudiants c'est un cœur de cible c'est
une population donc à risque on le sait
tous et il y a pas mal de soirées il y a
pas mal aussi de conduite à risque je
pense à l'alcool mais notamment entre
autres mais pas seulement et c'est vrai
que pour le coup on a une vraie
nécessité à venir les dépister
régulièrement en l'occurrence sur
Saint-Quentin on aimerait bien que ce
soit un peu plus que simplement une fois
par an nous on estime qu'il faudrait que
ce soit 2 à 3 fois par an pour
effectivement avoir une vraie action de
prévention l'association se déplace
aussi dans les centres commerciaux et
les coeurs de cité des Yvelines sur
l'ensemble de ces actions 2% des
visiteurs se révèlent assez repositifs
c'est plus que dans un centre de
dépistage fixe qui n'en détecte que 0,2%
dans l'année à chef prévention en
profite aussi pour faire connaître son
application tube pour trouver un
préservatif depuis son lancement l'année
dernière ce système qui permet de
géolocaliser préservatif et lieu de
dépistage a été téléchargée plus de 60
000 fois sur les smartphones
dimanche c'est l'heure d'été il faudra
avancer ses montres d'une heure une
heure de sommeil en moins mais pour une
heure de soleil en plus alors ceux qui
apprécient les activités en plein air
vont se réjouir évidemment de ce passage
à l'heure d'été instauré en France une
première fois en 1917 a abandonner à la
Libération et remis en place en mars
19676 après le choc pétrolier l'objectif
annoncé donc de ce passage à l'heure
d'été faire des économies d'énergie
selon une étude de 2009 qui a estimé que
l'heure d'été permettait d'économiser
4400 pardon gigawatts rien qu'en
éclairage alors des associations
militent toutefois contre ce changement
d'heure c'est votre cas il est dans le
gabarit bonsoir vous êtes la présidente
nationale de l'association contre
l'heure d'été double et vous êtes
yvelinoise qu'est-ce que vous reprochez
à l'heure d'été
il fait jour plus tard et ça permet de
faire des économies
vous parliez des activités des pleines
le matin c'est moins facile et en début
d'après-midi il fait plus chaud on
retarde les sorties il y a des effets
per dans tous les autres mais côté
énergie depuis des années plusieurs
études ont montré qu'il y avait des
circonsommation pour le chauffage
matinée sont plus froides pour la
climatisation et aussi parce qu'il y a
un supplément de trafic et donc en tout
si on tient compte des études
européennes et américains et bien les
bilans serait déjà plutôt négatif plutôt
négatif de leur
sommeil parce que du coup on se couche
forcément plus tard parce qu'il fait
jour plus tard oui tout à fait il y a
une perte de sommeil d'abord pour
s'adapter au changement mais après quand
les jours sont vraiment très longs
autour du solstice et d'été il y a il y
a c'est ce retard important de
l'obscurité notre monde du sommeil il a
mélatonine et les bloqué par la lumière
elle a besoin de évidemment d'obscurité
des lumières atténues pour pouvoir
trouver le sommet donc d'où des
problèmes surtout pour les enfants qui
ont besoin d'avantages de sommeil c'est
ça qui est nous ne nous étonnons pas que
la réforme intérimaire donc même si elle
a des vertus mais n'importe vraiment pas
des progrès et parce que on n'a pas tenu
compte que si on a si on perd un peu de
sommeil c'est trop juste tous les jours
de la semaine sans la pose du mercredi
et bien les enfants vont être fatigués
donc le changement d'heure l'heure d'été
ça ne résout pas les problèmes de
consommation d'énergie nous l'avait dit
et ça pose des problèmes de sur le
rythme chronobiologique le 24 mars à
Bruxelles il y a la réunion de trois
commissions européennes autour de cette
question qu'est-ce qui s'est dit ben
écoutez tout le monde était d'accord
pour souhaiter l'abandonne du système
heure d'été et des experts sont venus
pour dire à nouveau que le village
énergétiques n'étaient pas bon et il y
avait est-ce que ça peut changer les
choses est-ce que du coup demain il peut
y avoir une directive européenne qui
disent
pas facile parce que les députés
européennes qui qui sont qui ont la
meilleure volonté ils travaillent les
sujets mais ils ont ils sont
particulièrement pas des pouvoirs vous
savez il faut savoir que en Europe c'est
la Commission de Bruxelles et qui a les
pouvoirs des propositions et si les
Parlement fait des amendements
indirective il peut tous le rejeter et
la Commission veut pas bouger mais bon
on va faire en sorte que ça bouge notre
association va s'adresser à nouveau à
l'Allemagne pour parce que si la France
et l'Allemagne et donc demandé à la
Commission de revoir les systèmes et
bien ça ça serait sans doute décisif
parce que ça a bougé la fédération de
réussite qui abandonnait le système tout
ça c'est la fédération de réussite qui
est abandonné en 2014 je crois il y a
pas longtemps effectivement l'heure
d'été est-ce que vous êtes entendus au
niveau au niveau politique français je
crois que François Bayrou et Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan pour debout la France vont
plutôt dans votre sens
tout à fait le gouvernement de la
majorité socialiste qu'est-ce qu'on vous
répond aujourd'hui
qu'il souhaitait rouvrir les débats sur
leur d'été sans tabou c'était très
sympathique mais il n'a pas il n'a rien
fait parce que vous savez que il n'a
aucun conseiller qui soit scientifique
bon il est entouré de littéraires et
donc pour un problème qui avant tout
scientifique et qui est complexe et bien
c'est pas c'est pas l'idéal mais
peut-être
arrivera-t-il d'autant plus que
maintenant donc son ancienne compagne
Madame cyrilene Royale et au ministère
de l'écologie elle avait fait un rapport
où elle disait que les économies
d'énergie est insignifiante donc
l'espoir René pour votre association
c'est très clair c'est très clair
seulement il faut qu'on veuille regarder
la chose et je pense que qu'on arrivera
je ne sais pas quand mais on
on continue les combats et on dénonce ce
qui est énorme même si on gagne pas on
est obligé pour tout à cause de toutes
les victimes même des accidents de la
route qui augmente on est obligé de
dénoncer cette erreur et dernière
question votre association s'appelle
l'association contre leur d'été double
parce qu'il faut comprendre que du coup
avec ce passage à l'heure d'été la
France est en décalage de deux heures
par rapport au temps solaire
à l'heure du fuseau donc géographique et
qui est centrée sur le méridien des
Greenwich qui passe par son mur et
Tarbes et donc en hiver Déjà nous
avançons une heure ça devrait rendre
heureux des gens qui aiment ça et voir
donc ce qui cherche des économies toute
petite mais qu'ils veulent mais donc en
été ça va faire deux d'avance et c'est
un cas unique c'est un cas unique avec
l'Espagne qui aussi avancent beaucoup
mais qui justement il se posent des
questions et il a un message prendre en
hiver l'heure du donc du méridien donc
la France on avance de deux heures par
rapport au Soleil
unique au monde merci à vous d'être venu
sur le plateau de TV mais quand même
changer votre monde vous allez quand
même vous vous adapter quand même à
l'heure d'été non écoutez ou alors vous
restez c'est toujours
de mon portable
et beaucoup de et donc du saviez des
appareils où il leur apparaissent
automatiquement
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau du journal merci beaucoup avant
de nous quitter sa dernière information
notée ce renouveau rendez-vous politique
de la rédaction de tvfils le deuxième
tour des départementales c'est à vivre
en direct sur notre antenne à partir de
19h45 ce dimanche analyse commentaire
réaction à chaudes et candidats des
cantons de Trappes
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Maurepas plaisir
et sincère l'école et puis depuis les
bureaux centralisateurs avec nos équipes
de journalistes sur place et donc
dimanche en direct à partir de 19h45 une
émission présentée par Wilfried Richie
en partenariat avec Radio sensation ce
journal est maintenant terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas donc
dimanche avancez vos montres d'une heure
bonne soirée bon weekend